at least eight people have died in
turkey where wildfires are continuing to
rage for a sixth day residents of mugler
in the southwest who have been forced to
flee their villages as the flames edged
closer to their homes and tourists
staying at the turkish holiday resort of
bodrum
were evacuated and told to wait for
rescue boats and fresh wildfires erupted
nearby well live now to our special
correspondent alex portland
he's not far from bodrum goodness look
at that deeply worrying alex
well look at this look at this look at
this fire that's just a spark has just
landed right next to us
um and that shows just how quickly it
can catch a hold we've just come from
down that road look at that road it's
now getting overwhelmed by
fire at the end of that road is a small
village
of several thousand people um from
churches which is
a near bottom and just within the space
of the last 20 minutes or so
the fire has engulfed the whole of our
rear
road and has come up along the side and
is threatening to
overwhelm this area with there was mass
panic
in the village with dozens and dozens of
people
racing to get out of the area including
the firefighters
truckloads of firefighters pulling out
now we arrived there first thing this
morning
and these strong winds are part of the
reason why
it is um really gathering pace
let's move a bit further down kevin
because it's coming further behind us
and i don't want to get cut off
but um just keep going if you can
um and there was a lot of panic
in the village as we were there you can
see it it's coming down the sides of the
the hill there there was a lot of panic
in the village because they were pretty
much on their own
there wasn't uh firefighters uh we
arrived as they were actually taking
bottles of water and pulling out buckets
of
of water from their wells and trying to
douse the flames and protect their
property
a few firefighters turned up there was a
lot of complaints
about why there were so few of them and
of course we know that from the
turkish president that he has said the
country does not have
enough uh aircraft to carry water to
contain this
and they are being outpaced by the fire
completely outpaced by the flames and
the fire
you can see because of these strong
winds
maybe we should think about moving on in
a few
minutes it is moving at a rapid pace we
look
down there that's the way where we're
going and we don't want to be cut off
as i say people have been look at the
sheets of flames this is what we're up
again i think probably
we're going to have to cut short this
live and get back to you in a few
minutes when we get to a slightly
safer place because it's moving so
quickly it's very difficult to know
and predict where it's going to land and
as i say sparks are flying
all over the place but we'll get back to
you as soon as we can with an update
indeed alice get to safety would you
please thank you for bringing us that
though the dramatic scenes aren't they
will follow events there in turkey